listo para empezar el problema número
y dice lo siguiente si n&p su mente de
los mayores que uno n&p son enteros
mayores que uno lo voy a poner solamente
así son más grandes que uno pero nos
acordamos que son enteros y p es factor
de n 3 ok
como p es factor de n 3 lo voy a
escribir así en más tres en de más 3 lo
podemos ver como un cierto número que se
coloca por p esto quiere decir que pepe
ese factor de n 3 ok y p también es
factor de n 10 ok vamos escribirlo de la
misma manera en de más 10 es igual a
otro número no sé se me ocurre m m y ojo
no forzosamente debe ser la misma
constante puede ser una constante
distinta m porter porque pero también es
factor de n 10 ok
cuál es el valor de p
ok existirá un valor exacto para p
con estas dos ecuaciones
vamos a ver qué te parece si de esta
despejamos a él me va a quedar que nn es
igual a aporte
por ben x p - 3 - 3
ok y de están me quedaría que n es igual
a mp&mp
p
- 10
este es un problema que tiene que ver
con divisibilidad tengo o con factores
tengo un número que es factor de otro y
otro número que es factor de otro ahora
lo que logramos ser justo ahorita es
tener a la en despejada justo aquí tengo
el valor de n y el valor de l entonces
con esto puede igualar esta parte de
aquí y esta parte de aquí no te asustes
sé que son muchas letras en un principio
pero vamos a ver si podemos llegar a
alguna conclusión me va a quedar que acá
p - 3 es igual a mp menos 10 ok aunque
te parece sumó 10 de modos de actuación
de este lado me va a quedar que cabe más
7 menos 310 es 7 esto es igual y del
otro lado me va a quedar solamente mp mp
porque menos 10 más 10 se van a cancelar
ok
cada vez más 7 es igual a mp eso qué
quiere decir
date cuenta de lo siguiente fíjate bien
aquí tengo a p aquí tengo a p y también
la tengo aquí eso quiere decir que si yo
tengo a un número llamado p y le sumó 7
me da otro múltiplo de p un múltiplo de
p más 7 me da otro múltiplo de p eso
quiere decir que 77 también debe ser un
múltiplo de p y como 7 es múltiple b
pero además es un número primo el 7
solamente lo podemos descomponer en 1
o el 7 si tengo a un múltiplo de p y le
sumó 7 y neutro múltiplo de p eso quiere
decir que me debe de ser 7 y debe de ser
7 porque uno no se puede y uno no se
puede porque nos dicen que n iv pesos
mayores que uno entonces no queda de
otra
penn debe de ser 7 porque cuando yo
tengo a un múltiplo de p y le sumó un 7
me da otro múltiplo de p
dicho otra manera siempre fuera 7 de
aquí podremos escribir esto de la
siguiente manera como cada vez más p
igual a mp ok y de x factor será pp es
igual acá más uno y esto es igual a mp o
dicho de otra manera acá más uno es
igual a m no te espantes por tantas
letras no hay tanto problema lo más
importante es lo que yo quiero que veas
es que como le sumamos 7 y eso es muy
importante como estoy sumando 7 justo
aquí a un múltiplo de pep y me da otro
bp eso quiere decir que 7 es un múltiplo
de pm y 7 es un múltiplo de p o un
factor de p entonces solamente puede ser
17 son los únicos factores de 7 y por lo
tanto b debe de ser igual a 7 inclusive
lo podemos poner justo aquí imagínate
que en el vale en a más 3 es un múltiplo
de 7 entonces imagínate que en 3 estos
dos valen 21 entonces quiere decir que
en el vale 18 en este caso ok
18 más 3 21 y si a esto le sumó 7 sería
28 ok y si te das cuenta 21 es un
múltiplo de 728 y su nulo de 7 lo que
quiere decir que es un 7 o es más lo
podemos visualizar la siguiente manera
si yo me tomo n 10 que es un múltiplo de
p ok ya esto le quitó n menos 3 es decir
el otro múltiple
esto me va a dar 7 lo que quiere decir
que 7 debe de ser también un múltiplo de
pm porque estamos pasando de un múltiplo
p
a otro múltiplo de pep y eso quiere
decir entonces que 7 se tienen que ver
de forma
m por p vamos en otro número a a golpe
aporte pero no hay de otra
7 los únicos factores que tiene son 1 y
p por lo tanto de aquí estoy llegando a
que debe ser igual a 7
ok espero que más o menos haya entendido
esto tienen que ver mucho con factores y
con divisibilidad o que intercambió en
la pantalla fue unos problemas más
interesantes que hemos hecho pero vamos
hacer ahora el problema número 15 el
problema número 15 y tiene un cubo así
que vamos a hacer aquí el cubo
tengo por aquí déjeme cambiar de color
tengo por aquí la cara del cubo
imagínate que estás en mi cara del cubo
y después tengo una recta por acá
algo así otro evento por acá
y algo más o menos así después estas dos
se unen estoy intentando hacerlo lo más
padre posible recuerda que estoy
intentando ser siempre los dibujos de
una manera a que se entienda lo mejor
posible algo más o menos así
aquí después de estos dos se unen algo
más o menos así ok
hasta ahí creo que va bien no me está
quedando tan mal pero ahora viene el
problema de las líneas punteadas atrás
tenemos líneas punteadas y tengo algo
más o menos así lo deciden punteada por
aquí ok y después por aquí sube tengo
algo más o menos así va a subir esto
para acá y después hay que mover esto
para acá ok esto no me quedó también
pero creo que la podemos poner
bien bueno y me dan varios puntos me dan
un montón de puntos
me dicen que este de aquí es mi punto x
este de aquí es mi punto y esto de aquí
es un punto al este del medio es medio
punto mi punto en medio entre a sven
este de aquí es en este equipo es de y
este de aquí es el y me dicen que tanto
ve como sé cómo son los medios puntos de
cada una de las aristas ok y lo que me
están preguntando en este vídeo es cuál
es el ángulo más pequeño cuál es el
ángulo más pequeño si fijamos x y
jackman si nos fijamos en xy y nos
fijamos también en uno de todos estos
puntos por ejemplo en b tengo este
ángulo de kim este de aquí y lo que me
voy a preguntar es cuánto vale este
ángulo a comparación de a no se puede
tomar metro podría tomarme por ejemplo a
de x hasta ahí
voy a regresar allí y siempre voy a
empezar en x lo estoy fijando ahora en
este ángulo o por ejemplo puede hacer lo
mismo con cm
vamos a hacer lo voy a cambiar de color
puede fijarme en este de aquí de x ac y
después me regreso a james en este
ángulo de aquí déjame ponerlo este de
aquí ok o también podría ser lo mismo
con d
vamos a acabar podría ser lo mismo con
de irme hasta de ok y después regresar
me está bien y fijarme en este ángulo de
aquí en este de aquí ok o en dado caso
con él
este sería mi última opción así que me
podría ir de aquí hasta de x déjenme
cambiar de color
de equis y el mes está en ok y
regresarme hasta el ok ahora fíjate que
este sería mi ángulo lo primero que
podemos hacer y creo que se ve muy claro
es que podemos descartar hace ya porque
si no tendríamos dos respuestas sé que
no son mis respuestas porque tienen el
mismo ángulo este ángulo de verde es lo
mismo que este ángulo de blanco porque
si te das cuenta hacemos lo mismo vamos
de x hasta uno de los dos puntos medios
de estas dos este aristas ya sea esta o
ya sea ésta y de regreso por lo tanto
tenemos exactamente el mismo ángulo
entonces ni sé ni son mis respuestas
ahora vamos a fijarnos en qué es lo que
pasa con a b y d y para esto quiero que
te fijes en lo siguiente si tenemos la
distancia x james supongamos que de aquí
o no no me equivoque esta herramienta
perdón perdón
imagínate que de aquí hasta acá es xy
imagínate que de aquí hasta acá y es más
lo voy a poner así
es x ok este es bien y yo me tomo un
ángulo supongamos que hago un ángulo con
otro cierto punto aquí entonces llegó
hasta este punto y de aquí su ok fíjate
bien en este ángulo en este ángulo que
le voy a poner el nombre de teta a
comparación de otro ángulo ahora
imagínate que yo hago lo mismo
exactamente lo mismo pero ahora me voy
hasta un punto más alejado me voy hasta
acá y me regreso qué ángulo será más
grande te dan o este ángulo que le voy a
poner alfa alfaa o theta será un ángulo
más grande bueno pues la respuesta es
que el ángulo más grande es teta y eso
es porque esta línea está mucho más
inclinada que esta línea estas líneas
suaviza más este ángulo que esta línea
que se abre una manera muy rápida es más
lo podemos utilizar de la siguiente
manera mediante cuando tomamos a una
línea por aquí un punto por aquí y este
punto sube hasta
ahora fíjate en este ángulo de aquí si
te das cuenta este ángulo es mucho más
grande casi es un ángulo de 90 grados
que este ángulo que ya bajó un poco su
tamaño a que este ángulo que ya bajó
mucho más su tamaño porque estamos
fijándonos en puntos mucho más alejados
este punto está mucho más lejos que este
punto que este punto porque te cuento
todo esto porque dicho de otra manera lo
que voy a buscar es cuál es el punto más
alejado hay quien está siendo este de
aquí y no voy a fijar en cuenta el punto
más alejado ahí entre b a c d y e y el
punto más alejado que encontremos allí
nos va a dar el ángulo más pequeño
porque esto está fijo eso no va a
cambiar entonces esencialmente estaremos
fijándonos en puntos más más más lejanos
y entonces tomaríamos ángulos pegas pero
más pero más pequeños que es justo lo
que yo quiero cual es el ángulo más
pequeño
a ver si nos fijamos en la distancia de
allí pues en definitiva es mucho más
grande la distancia de aa
porque de hecho es el punto medio
entonces de ahí es dos veces la
distancia que hay desde allí entonces
puede ser mi candidato y voy a cancelar
a ver ya cancela ven ya que se le hace
en llegan se le hace ya porque están en
la misma distancia y me queda solamente
am y de que será más larga la distancia
que hay de ayer o la distancia que hay
desde ayer ahora lo podemos visualizar
la siguiente manera
déjeme hacer aquí un cuadrado voy a ver
si te convence y mediante quiten un
cuadrado este es de aquí o no cambiamos
de herramienta este de tim este de aquí
pase de james es decir va a ser este
equipo y por lo tanto el que está a su
izquierda el que está su izquierda va a
ser a este de aquí es am y después de
que está en el otro extremo éste va a
ser de este de aquí va a ser de ok
supongamos que esta distancia vale x
ok si esta distancia vale x qué
distancia el más grande está de aquí
está de aquí o me puedo tomar tal vez
esta otra desde allí desde ayer que le
voy a poner el nombre de z que es más
grande la distancia de ayer o la
distancia del de y bueno se nota
claramente en este cuadrado que la
distancia más grande es desde ayer y es
más lo podemos ver de la siguiente
manera con un teorema de pitágoras con
un teorema de pitágoras es muy claro que
existe es un ángulo recto esto es un
ángulo recto este es un triángulo
rectángulo entonces z es mucho más
grande que x porque recuerda que se está
al cuadrado es exactamente lo mismo que
la suma de los catetos elevados al
cuadrado por lo tanto ya puedo concluir
la distancia del ave es más grande que
la distancia de ahí y esto se nota
claramente creo que no hay tanto que
explica en este momento por lo tanto
esta también se va y me queda que la
distancia más larga de ye a un punto de
estos que está aquí es de ave por lo
tanto mi respuesta es
de es el punto más alejado ayer y
tuvimos el punto más alejado allí
entonces la distancia de allí es la más
larga entre todos los puntos y como la
distancia desde allí es la más larga
entre todos los puntos el ángulo que se
forma este de azul este de aquí va a ser
el ángulo más pequeño entre todos los
que están aquí bien mi respuesta es el
cis hotel de lujo problema número 15 que
creo que no estuvo tan difícil era un
problema completamente visual y muy pero
muy intuitivo a base de problemas número
16 y espero que me dé tiempo a el
problema 16 es el último así que vamos a
meter de velocidad a ver si lo podemos
lograr problemas 16 dice si x por james
esto es igual a 7 y por otra parte x-men
x-men oye esto es igual a 5 entonces lo
que me preguntan es cuánto vale x
cuadrada bien menos x
a cuánto equivale esto bueno pues que te
parece si empezamos con esto
esto lo que yo quiero saber y vamos a
tratar de factorizar de aquí lo más que
se pueda para utilizar estos datos este
y este así que de esta primera parte voy
a actualizar una equis me va a quedar x
que multiplica a xy ok esto porque yo sé
el valor de que james y de igual manera
para acá - y aquí van factorizar yen y
hay que multiplicar a x lion ok esto lo
hago porque ya sé el valor de x jermaine
y fíjate bien que aquí tengo x por equis
y me da x 4 de ayer ya esto le voy a
quitar por equis james lo cual me da
existe cuadrado entonces hasta aquí no
he hecho nada más que una igualdad pero
ahora date cuenta que ya tengo un factor
común aquí tengo a xy multiplicando a x
aquí tengo a x multiplicando en jr por
lo tanto qué te parece si lo factor
izamos me va a quedar x gent x gent que
multiplica aunque esto es igual en
primer lugar multiplica x a x porque x
gent x x es lo mismo que
por equis bien estos dos forman a este y
en segundo lugar multiplica
- james multiplica a menos porque x x
menos me da este de aquí ok le quisieron
paréntesis es decir que esencialmente lo
que tengo aquí es la multiplicación de x
por james que multiplica a su vez a x
menos 10 y que crees de que yo puedo
utilizar la información de aquí arriba
de lujo creo que sí vamos a acabar este
problema esto es lo mismo que x james
pero guille vale 77 esto utilizando la
información de que arriba esto que a su
vez va a multiplicar a x menos james
pero x menos vale 5 7 x 5 lo cual por
cierto es 35 la respuesta a este
problema es 35 y se me ha acabado el
tiempo así que lo logramos terminamos
todos los problemas de esta sección
número 8 de este examen número 7 en el
siguiente vídeo vamos a empezar un nuevo
examen y una nueva sección de hecho es
el último examen de este libro del libro
s/a
hasta la próxima